Today we'll be speaking with Dr Kevin Ochsner,
who's a professor of psychology at Columbia University on emotion regulation and
the brain doctor Ochsner received his phd in psychology from Harvard University
where he also received postdoctoral training and social psychology.
He later received additional training in functional neuroimaging at Stanford
University where he subsequently held the position of a research scientist.
He's currently a professor of Psychology at Columbia University and director of
the social cognitive and affective neuroscience laboratory.
His lab studies,
the psychological and neuro processes involved in emotion,
self regulation,
person perception and their interactions.
He's received various awards for his research and teaching,
including the American Psychological Association's division three new
investigator award,
the cognitive neuroscience societies young investigator award,
and the Columbia University's Distinguished Faculty award.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Kevin Ochsner.
So welcome Kevin.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for inviting me to talk with you
anytime.
What I'd like to ask you about saying what I think a lot of people would like to
know is what got you first started,
uh,
studying emotion in the first place.
Can you tell us a bit about that journey?
Sure.
Uh,
I guess for most people,
uh,
or at least in my case,
it starts when I was,
uh,
just a grade school student and I started noticing that,
so many people's emotional reactions,
uh,
seem to be a product of their life history.
So whether it was in my family or even my friends in the neighborhood or in
classes,
and I found myself trying to figure out what their history was that led them to
have the experiences that they had today.
Uh,
and although that was in some sense,
the seed that grew into the career I have now a one twist is that I didn't
realize how much I was interested in this until I was in Grad school studying
something else entirely.
Uh,
well,
it's not something else entirely.
I was studying memory and attention on,
I was studying that because when I was in college,
um,
I was an engineering and English major and I took as an elective what now would
be called mind brain and behavior.
I loved it.
One of the professors got me working in her lab.
I thought that was really fun,
but she studied attention and I worked in a couple of other labs and studied
memory and I thought this is really cool.
But I think we realized that what I thought was really cool was working in those
labs,
not necessarily the content of the science.
And,
uh,
I went to Grad school to study memory and attention and not that those are
perfectly worthy topics to study.
They're wonderful.
They just worked for me.
And about two months into Grad school I realized I needed to study emotion.
Um,
but I hadn't until that point realize you could do that as a career.
Uh,
and from then I started slowly but surely changing my trajectory away from
straight cognitive phenomenon to studying emotion,
uh,
and social behavior more broadly.
Very interesting.
So that actually through to the next question I want to ask you,
which is a bit about your word work now on emotion.
So your work has really pioneered this field that's looked at how can our brain
play a role in either,
you know,
kind of harnessing are reigning in our emotions are really amplifying them.
And so I'd love to hear your thoughts on what you see as some of the most
fundamental discoveries about neuroscience and as it relates to emotion
regulation.
So how does our brain really play a role in harnessing our feelings?
Well,
that's a great question.
Um,
and I wish it,
this one I could answer in three soundbites.
I'll do my best to sort of boil down two or three things that I think are
particularly cool.
So,
uh,
one is,
has to do with a particular way of regulating your emotion that's captured by
everyday aphorisms.
Like every dark cloud has a silver lining or look on the bright side.
And so on these aphorisms capture the idea that by changing the way you think
about the world,
you can change your emotional response to it.
And that particular skill that we seem to have a really captured my interest.
And I wanted to understand how did that happen in the brain so that we can
understand not just behaviourally that it does work,
but,
uh,
at a slightly more mechanistic level,
how does it work?
What is actually going on inside the brain when we find the silver lining in a
dark cloud.
Uh,
and we've used a functional magnetic resonance imaging as our primary tool here,
which allows us to look at what parts of the brain have more blood flow when
you're having particular kinds of thoughts or feelings.
And what we've found,
uh,
in my laboratory and now dozens of other laboratories around the world is that
when you elicit an emotional response,
you're activating parts of the brain that are often evolutionarily old.
And uh,
they in a kind of a bottom up driven by the world kind of way trigger an
emotional response.
But then if you want to effortfully changed the way you think about it,
to find that silver lining,
you use evolutionarily newer parts of the brain up here in your frontal lobe.
It's the lobes of the brain behind the frontal bone of your skull,
which in me,
not the hairless wonder here is quite prominent.
Uh,
and these areas of the frontal lobe are involved in generating a story,
creating a new narrative for the meaning of the situation that then kind of
harnesses activation of the subcortical systems and shifts them around as a
function of the way you're thinking about the world.
So if you think about a bad situation like visiting your sick uncle in the
hospital who just had a surgery,
you focus on the fact that,
oh,
he could be getting better.
He could be getting well,
these frontal regions will come online and might diminish activity in a brain
structure like you've made Dilla.
But if instead you think,
oh,
uncle Larry isn't a great deal of pain,
he might much worse.
It's going to be devastated.
I really stresses me out.
You'll be using these same frontal regions,
but now you're amping up activity in the system's important for triggering your
initial emotional response.
So it's not like there's any simple idea that,
oh,
you turn on the frontal lobe,
you turn off emotion.
It's not like that.
It's all about the meaning that you ascribe or the way in which classically in
psychology you'd say you a praise of the meeting of a situation that's
important.
So that's the first I think fundamental insight is that when you're cognitively
reframing the meaning of an emotional situation,
you're relying on parts of the frontal lobe that are important for all other
kinds of cock,
higher cognitive function in general language,
holding information in working memory,
controlling the focus of your attention.
It's really pretty much the same regions.
And in that sense,
these cognitive forms of emotion regulation are an instance of using cognitive
control over emotion instead of cognitive control over memory or cognitive
control over attention.
Um,
so that to me it was actually kind of profound because we really didn't know how
emotional regulation,
especially of this sort was going to be organized.
Um,
another thing that I thought was particularly interesting was that this ability
to cognitively reframe the meaning of a situation would work all the way down to
the level of very evolutionarily old brain structures that we might not have
thought our everyday thoughts and reasoning could penetrate.
So,
um,
for a while the received wisdom was that this brain structure,
the amygdala would lay down,
for example,
traces of a fear memory that were indelible.
Joseph Ledoux is famous at Nyu for doing the seminal studies in this regard.
So when we started waiting in here and doing these emotion regulation studies,
it was big news that you could just modify the image that was response simply by
changing quickly the way that you think about something.
Because the idea was,
oh my gosh,
if the middle is going to respond to something that's gruesome or nasty,
that's almost an obligatory response will hijack your brain.
In fact,
that was the popular term for science writers like Daniel Goleman,
they'd say,
you have an Amygdala hijacking.
Oh,
no,
read on your brain.
Um,
but it turned out it's not quite so simple as that as alluring and interesting
as those kinds of metaphors are,
as we all know,
they're useful up to a point.
The trends at the reality is a bit more complicated.
So that I think is the second thing that's really cool is that just by changing
your high level thoughts about the meaning of an emotional listening situation,
you can penetrate all the way down to even your brainstem and changed the way
really evolutionarily old primitive brain stem centers are encoding whether
something's threatening or not interested.
To me that's with,
maybe that's a long winded answer.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
It doesn't make me think a lot about how,
I mean you're giving us really interesting examples about how people used to
think about emotion and the way in which we would or would not be able to
regulate and it just kind of draws back to this notion of well what is emotion
and emotion regulation in the first place?
We can relate to it in our everyday lives.
We have these beliefs about how emotions,
like you said,
hijack our brain,
but really trying to define these two terms is really thorny for a lot of
researchers and I wonder for you especially looking at this through lens of
neuroscience,
how do you really tease apart what emotion and emotion regulation is?
And can the brain actually support this distinction in your mind?
Well,
I love how you asked some simple questions,
Jean,
and they're just so easy to answer.
Um,
so I mean,
of course that's another great question and this distinction between generating
an emotion on the one hand and then regulating it on the other,
um,
is of course,
uh,
it's really fundamental in many areas of psychology and it's,
it's extremely useful to make that distinction often,
uh,
in behavioral context where you're a clinician who wants to try and have a,
a working model of what's a good way to have a therapeutic intervention,
whether it's a conduct behavioral intervention,
you don't talk therapy intervention,
uh,
psychopharmacological intervention.
You know,
if you can frame that in terms of they have some type of um,
perhaps maladaptive initial emotional response or then you modify their ability
to regulate that in some way.
This distinction between generation or regulation can be very powerful and
useful.
But then when you start looking at the brain,
things get a little more blurry.
It turns out because most of our everyday examples of emotion generation on the
one hand and regulation on the other frame generation as a very automatic,
obligatory,
reflexive process as if it never involves much higher order of thought.
And the other hand frame regulation as necessarily this consciously gold ribbon
effortful,
the liberate time consuming process,
it turns out that's not the complete picture.
And emotions can be generated through deliberative effort full top down thought.
If you've ever been sitting in an arm chair on a fall or winter's day as the
light goes down earlier than you'd expect,
you're reading a book or You're surfing the web on your computer and suddenly
you noticed it's gotten dark all around you.
Did you lock the front door?
Oh,
what's that creek over there?
There's a strange sound in the other room and so on.
You start cognitively elaborating a scenario that from the top down we'll
generate an emotion and we've actually found that that will turn on the Amygdala
as well.
So there's a route by which controlled top down processes normally thought of as
part of regulation can actually be involved in the emotion generation process.
And then conversely,
there are forms of emotion regulation w that I don't require conscious,
top down effort in order to change your emotional response.
So for example,
um,
if you've learned that,
uh,
and in say,
a classic context that's studied by animal researchers,
a rat learns that a light predicts a shock.
You know,
for us,
you might learn that there's a particular street corner that predicts really
scary traffic.
So as you approached the street corner,
you start getting a little anxious because it's a little dodgy.
It's like,
you know,
playing an old video game for the 1970s trying to get across the street.
And so you have a little anticipatory fear,
anxiety,
anxieties.
You come up to the intersection.
Well,
uh,
it turns out that if over time you have no negative consequences in the face of
if you're a rat the light or if you're a person approaching that intersection
over time,
you'll extinguish what was previously this anticipatory anxiety,
that sort of anxious,
fearful response because you've had no negative consequences follow from that
expectation.
It turns out that involves completely different parts of the brain that are
involved in this conscious effort,
full top down reappraisal.
In fact,
it just involves the brain systems that are involved in initially learning or
acquiring an emotional response in the first place.
And,
uh,
and in fact,
expressing that emotion.
So it says,
if there are forms of regulation that just happened by dint of relearning,
oh,
this isn't really such a bad,
scary thing anymore,
and that doesn't require this effort full top down control.
So is that just learning to generate a new emotion,
is that implicitly automatically learning to regulate it?
Right.
It depends.
Right?
It depends on what the purpose is of asking the question.
So,
uh,
I mean that's my long winded round about way of coming back to saying whether
you want to call something generation or regulation really depends on your
purposes.
If it's really useful to make that distinction.
St and clinical context,
by all means make it.
If you're a neuroscientist who's trying to characterize the operation of a
specific brain system,
it's not going to break down in terms of this is a regulation region where this
is just a generation region.
Almost never does it break down that simply
if only emotion regulation where simple.
Right?
Right.
It only,
anything we study about,
people were simple.
I suppose neither of us would have jobs,
so thank goodness it's complicated and we don't have,
you know,
short soundbite answers to everything.
Right.
I agree.
I mean I think there's such interest in the complexity and I think we should be
unafraid as a scientist and just interested people to embrace the complexity of
it and try to understand it.
Well.
I think one of the really cool things you've done when you talk about embracing
complexity as you've taken it to a next level of complexity by trying to look at
clinical populations,
right,
where we know that emotion regulation goes awry.
And I think that's one of the really interesting things that I've been reading
about in your research.
I know a lot of people are excited about.
And so,
I mean,
one of the questions,
and this is the final question about your research,
I promise it's just sort of what your thoughts are about how emotion regulation
goes awry,
um,
especially in the brain for individual suffering from emotional disorders.
And I know your work has looked at populations ranging from individuals with
borderline personality disorder to substance abuse.
What's different in these individuals?
That's another great question.
So,
um,
let me start to answer that question or attempt to answer that question by
talking about,
um,
our approach to taking the work we do in the laboratory with sort of typically
developing adults,
uh,
and then applying it to these clinical contexts.
So our idea,
uh,
and I think this is a grow increasingly common one in the field,
is that you first have to have a benchmark,
uh,
an understanding,
a model of the basic ability as it works effectively for your typically
developing individual.
And so in our case,
we want to have these models of how different kinds of frontal systems maybe
involved in influencing the activity and often some cortical systems that and
that in that interaction you have regulation on the one hand and generation on
the other and that allows you to ask,
okay,
for a given patient population or clinical,
uh,
context,
is there a change in the way they initially trigger or generate a response to a
stimulus?
So if I've got borderline personality disorder and I have fundamental aspect
instability and a tendency to anxiously expect and overreact to potential cues
that someone's rejecting me,
then I might be particularly sensitive to social stimuli,
facial expressions,
any Q that might remind me of a time when I was lonely or rejected and so on.
You could ask,
am I just hyper sensitive to those kinds of queues?
On the other hand,
do we have a problem marshaling cognitive resources to regulate or modify that
response or even say psychologically distanced myself from that situation so I
don't have to be a victim of an initial impulsive tendency to say,
oh,
I really angry and anxious now because you seem to not be feeling too good about
me.
Um,
and so in this way like framing things in this way,
we can go in there with our um,
experimental methods and our brain imaging techniques and then ask what's going
on behavioral and in the brain.
And in the case of borderline personality disorder,
one thing we found is that some of the control systems that should be signaling
that,
hey,
I'm having an affect of response now I might not want to have those alarms.
Systems don't seem to be operating normally and someone with borderline
personality disorder and in fact when they try the turn down,
there are affective response.
They actually take the admit those response and Jack it up
and
the alarm system that should be saying,
hey,
something wrong is happening here.
It doesn't go off.
In fact,
its activity goes down.
It's as if they at we're not being told to do anything,
are trying to kind of keep themselves from thinking about the situation.
But as soon as you force them to think about a potentially stressful situation,
even if it's already having a negative impact on them,
it only makes things worse for them.
And they seem to be,
the control system seems to be ineffective in signaling the need to regulate.
So that's one interesting insight we've had about worldwide using our model of
emotion regulation that's really about characterizing the nature of disordered
aspect of response in that population.
Another way you can apply are these kinds of basic models of emotion.
Regulation is in a more of a treatment mode or a mode where you want to develop,
um,
or apply your say methods for studying emotion regulation to a clinical context
where you could be helping a population and learn to cope more effectively with
whatever their maladaptive aspect of responses.
And so here there's work that we've done on substance abuse with one of your
colleagues there at Yale.
A former student in my lab had he Cobar,
she was the lead person on this work.
And here we studied smokers,
uh,
where the interest wasn't understanding how on the one hand a smoker might have
an initial,
uh,
differentially strong bottom up positive appetitive craving response to a cue
that reminds them of a cigarette.
So it can be a photograph of a burning cigarette and someone's hand,
um,
it could be a picture of someone smoking,
even just a pack of cigarettes.
All of those cues are known to elicit positive aspect of response that leads us
smoker to crave smoking a cigarette at that moment.
So we can ask,
do the brain systems involved in generating a positive affect of response or
recognizing that's a potentially rewarding thing out there in the world to those
respond more strongly on the one hand or on the other.
If you ask them to try and effortfully regulate that response,
is there a diminishment in their capacity to turn down that response?
And what was really intriguing that we found was while sure they have a stronger
response to uh,
say cigarettes or cues that elicit creating for cigarettes,
then say a food cue that elicits a desire to eat that delicious chocolate Sundae
or that chocolate chip cookie or you know,
in this holiday season there's any number of temptations around.
Yeah,
they respond more strongly,
but they're able to effectively turn it off using kind of cognitive reappraisal
like techniques from the top down and then involve this action from prefrontal
regions turning off a region,
a supportable structure called the ventral striatum,
evolutionarily old,
really important for encoding things that are rewarding and reinforcing and that
in turn diminish their craving.
There's this nice three step pathway that heady described.
What was striking is that smokers were as effective at turning down their
craving for cigarettes as they weren't turning down their cravings for food.
And what's exciting about that is that it seems to provide an initial insight
into the pathway by which treatments like cognitive behavioral therapy,
which are really,
really similar to the ways we study reappraisal in the lab might be effective.
And we know that cognitive behavioral therapies can be very effective for
smokers.
And so in this context,
what we might be doing is starting to describe the brain pathways that underlie
effective forms of treatment for a substance abusing population.
And we can then potentially generalize that to other populations.
Ask How some individuals with substance abuse issues might effectively or
ineffectively rely on those pathways.
Um,
and so on.
We're now taking this work,
uh,
and extending it to the study of alcohol and alcohol abuse.
Uh,
and I know your colleague had,
he has taken it and extended in other directions as well.
So thanks for that.
I mean,
in your sort of thinking about now what is in store next,
right.
So this leads me to ask you,
this is another easy question,
but what do you see in store for the future study of emotion?
Boy,
I think,
um,
one of the exciting things about research is you never know what's next.
Um,
one answer could be,
I just don't know because it's going to be,
there's so many different people working on different aspects of emotion that
it's hard to predict what new insights we're going to have.
A,
another way to answer that question is to say,
certainly we're gonna try to deepen our understanding of the basic ways in
which,
um,
cortical and subcortical systems are involved in emotion generation on the one
hand and regulation on the other with,
I think in the next 10 years we're going to describe networks for everything
where it's going to be,
not just parts of prefrontal cortex modulating brain systems for detecting
threats are encoding,
uh,
rewards.
It's going to be each one of those things will be more of a network and then
there'll be an increasing recognition that we can't understand the brain basis
of any behavior,
let alone emotion.
Um,
in terms of us few bit part players on a stage,
it's really like an orchestra where every part of the brain is an instrument
playing different kinds of nodes in synchrony or asynchronously with others.
In the case of dysfunction potentially.
And there's something in the aggregate about the music that's made by the notes
played by all these different instruments and that you can't understand the
phenomenon in our case of motion,
unless you understand the way all the instruments play together as kind of a
network or a group.
And I think that is a really exciting frontier for,
uh,
the interface between psychology and neuroscience is how to characterize the way
in which this sort of orchestra,
all the instruments that play in your brain and your mind give rise to the
phenomena that we care about.
That's a really beautiful metaphor.
I think a lot of people will use that as a way to guide how they think about
emotion and where to go with it.
Um,
and so the last question I want to ask you,
Kevin,
is,
you know,
what advice would you have for students or just people more generally who are
interested in embarking in the study of this?
You know,
sort of confusing but beautiful orchestra,
you know,
if emotion.
Uh,
that's a great question.
I guess.
I think two things.
So one is,
uh,
read a lot,
you know,
read broadly,
read about emotion,
uh,
but also read outside of emotion research,
because it might provide with insights into the way emotion works that if you
are only reading research and emotion you might not otherwise have.
So in my own example,
I had a pretty big base of knowledge just about cognitive neuroscience in
general and the study of memory and attention in particular.
And so I used that as my foundation when I came into studying emotion and I
wasn't sort of brought up in my,
uh,
academic adolescence,
if you will,
in a lab that had strong preexisting ideas and a long history about the way
emotion was supposed to be studied.
In some sense,
that might've freed me up to have an outsider's perspective on it and say,
oh,
okay,
I can approach emotion the way a cognitive neuroscientist and I don't have to be
beholden to any prior views necessarily.
I mean,
obviously that has its pluses and minuses.
Uh,
and I,
once I started reading more broadly to emotion,
I felt like I could integrate things in a,
in a somewhat unique way.
And I think that's important for anyone interested in any phenomenon read not
just about that phenomenon,
but other allied things you don't know where inspiration will come from.
I think the other piece of advice I might get I might give is simply to get
involved in doing research.
And if it weren't for the fact that I did that in my,
uh,
my own college career,
I don't think I'd be where I am today even though I feel like this is absolutely
the perfect career for me.
I couldn't possibly imagine doing anything else if I hadn't got involved in
research and being on the ground in the research trenches,
if you will,
collecting data,
running subjects,
thinking hard about the phenomenon that I was studying and what it means and how
do I develop methods and we'll have to study on what am I doing if I hadn't been
doing that,
I don't think I would have had,
um,
the hands on experience to ground my highfalutin interests and high concept
stuff,
you know,
otherwise,
it's kind of just,
it's armchair philosophy if you don't kind of get in there and study it.
So read more and get in the trenches.
Yes.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking with us today,
Kevin.
Um,
this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Kevin Ochsner from
Columbia University.